[Music]
Borderlands has been thrilling players
since 2009 with its unique comic style
crazy characters and lots of insane
action this successful combination has
led to the game series selling more than
50 million copies worldwide of course
this also attracts the attention of
Hollywood which is why preparations for
the Borderlands movie started back in
2015 the release is now finally
approaching so it's high time to take a
look behind the scenes when is
Borderlands being released in theater
who's in it and what is it all about
well we got all the answers for you here
in this
video the game Story begins on the
planet known as Pandora with the
discovery of a mysterious Vault created
by an ancient alien race this place
promises incredible power and wealth
which is why huge corporations do their
utmost to take control of it but all
sorts of mercenaries Soldiers of Fortune
and Shady characters so-called Vault
Hunters also set out to achieve this
goal the world of Borderlands is a
dystopian mix of wild west Aesthetics
and futuristic technology at the same
time it looks like something straight
out of a comic book the violence and
black humor are just as exaggerated
Pandora is filled with dangerous
creatures strange Bandits and giant
monsters in fact a great setting for an
entertaining action
film the Borderlands movie can make use
of an enormous amount of stories and
characters from the original games since
all the important roles and actors are
already known we can take a closer look
at what we can expect who are the heroes
and who are the villains here are the
details the main character of the
Borderlands movie is Lilith who was
already a playable character in the
first game she is a siren a human who
has developed special abilities after
coming into contact with alien
technology she can make herself
invisible and cause explosions for
example she is played by the renowned
actress Kate Blanchette who most people
will probably remember as gadriel in The
Lord of the Rings
movies as in the original game Roland
fights alongside her as an ex-member of
the unscrupulous mercenary company
Crimson Lance he is a born Soldier and a
specialist in all kinds of weapons his
character is played by comedian and
actor Kevin
Hart likewise part of the team is Dr
Patricia Tannis an unusual scientist she
is an expert in technology and has a
keen mind but it is accompanied by her
social awkwardness and strange Behavior
often plagued by Madness and obsessions
tennis contributes to her isolated
lifestyle she's played by Hollywood star
and Halloween Legend Jam Lee
Curtis one character that most fans are
probably looking forward to is the role
of Tiny Tina Tina is a charismatic and
headstrong character in The borderlines
franchise she is a young explosives
expert with an unconventional sense of
humor after a traumatic experience she
mainly uses this sense of humor as a
coping mechanism Tina is known for her
bubbly sometimes manic nature and her
penchant for explosive experiments she
is played by Ariana a green blat we have
already been able to see as young Gamora
in Avengers Infinity War she also made
her last TV appearance as a younger
version of a well-known character in the
Star Wars series
Ahsoka wherever Tiny Tina is her great
defender C is not far away C is a kind
of mentor to Tiny Tina and tries to
protect her from the worst aspects of
Pandora C's backstory is one of inner
conflict and a continuous battle for his
sanity his constant urge to fight and
destroy makes him a complex character in
the video games he is a so-called
Berserker he is characterized Above All
by his resilience and enormous strength
in the movie Creek is played by German
actor Florian monu who most of you may
know as Victor Drago from Creed 2 and
Creed
3 one character in particular is an
integral part of Borderlands the Lively
robot clap trap in the games he guides
us through the main missions and is busy
making our lives miserable and saving
his own butt for most of the time we are
are very excited to find out how he will
be integrated into the story of the
movie he is dubbed by none other than
the legendary comedian actor and
musician Jack Black an excellent choice
even though fans of the games will
certainly have to get used to the new
voice of course our heroes will also
face the one or other opponent from the
video game series one of the characters
who made it into the Borderlands film
adaptation is crom who is known for his
ruthless nature and his enormous arsenal
of weapons Dutch bodybuilder Olivier
rter speaks on the role of this Bandit
leader also in the movie is General Knox
a member of the mercenary troops Crimson
Lance however the character is given a
new look for the film here the character
is not yet a general and is also a woman
played by Janina gavankar the new
interpretation of the character has
already caused some discontent among
fans Atlas will play a key role in the
Borderlands movie Atlas is actually
known to players as a corporation
supplying a wide range of weapons but
according to official information
Atlas is an important character in the
movie we can only guess whether this
will actually be the atlas CEO Reese
strongfork known from the games he will
be played by the Venezuelan actor Edgar
Ramirez similarly atlas's daughter is
said to be an essential part of the plot
although her actual casting is not known
yet the only name in the cast with out
an assigned role so far is Haley Bennett
which is why we assume that she will
play this part Bennett is known from the
psychological Thriller swallow for
example the Borderland series is known
for its many crazy Side characters who
are also set to make an appearance in
the movie we will see for instance the
battle arena operator mad Moxy portrayed
by Gina gersa Cheyenne Jackson plays
weapons manufacturer Jacobs while
Charles babalola takes on the role of
naturalist and Big Game Hunter sir
hammerlock Benjamin Byron Davis also
appears as arms dealer Marcus concade we
are particularly looking forward to the
mechanic Duo scooter and Ellie who
provide us with all kinds of crazy
companions in the video games in the
movie scooter is played by Steven Boer
while Ellie is played by Ryan Kirby
Redmond with such an extensive storyline
of the games one question naturally
arises what is the plot of the
Borderlands movie we already know that
it is a standalone story within the
Borderlands Universe it is not supposed
to be part of the game cannon even if we
do get to see all kinds of characters
and locations from the games Lilith will
play the leading role she is
commissioned by Atlas to find his
daughter on Pandora so she reluctantly
returns to her home planet and assembles
a group of former Vault hunters and
other allies to join the search atlas's
daughter is also said to possess a key
to unimaginable power it remains to be
seen whether this is a reference to the
Vault mentioned in the video games the
story seems to be very similar to that
of the games which of course is sure to
make the fans excited apart from that no
details are known about the group's
upcoming adventure and how the many
characters will be integrated into the
story the development of the Borderlands
movie has been a wild few years in May
2015 saw and Insidious author Lee w l
was approached to pen and direct a film
adaptation of the video game series for
Lionsgate films the official
announcement was then made in August
2015 with well-known Marvel veterans Ari
and AI arid as producers in April 2016
the rather unknown Aaron Berg was
suddenly asked to write the screenplay
before 22 Jump Street author Orin uziel
assumed this task in June 2018 in
February 2020 horror veteran Eli Roth
was then confirmed his director now
script was to be written by Craig Mason
renowned creator of Chernobyl and The
Last of Us filming took place in
Budapest in the early summer of 2021 in
January 2023 it was revealed that the
film would undergo 2 weeks of additional
shooting under the direction of Deadpool
director Tim Miller and as if four
writers for Borderlands weren't enough
Craig Mason was officially replaced by
Joe cromby in June 2023 2 years after
the main shooting was completed Mason
had a falling out with the production
and had his name removed from the credit
no nobody really knows who is behind the
new role according to Mason it is at
least not synonymous with his own name
as you can see it seems as though the
production took place under extremely
messy circumstances there is no trailer
for the Borderlands movie yet but the
theatrical release is already slated for
August 9th 2024 we can therefore easily
imagine that at least a teaser trailer
won't be too long in coming that was all
the information about the upcoming
Borderlands movie do you think the movie
adaptation of the hit game can be a
success share your opinion in the
comments and give the video a thumbs up
if you enjoyed our short preview thanks
for
[Music]
watching